i
tranquille qui avait sa
librairie en face. On regarde
ça. Merci beaucoup à vous deux.
- C'est lui qui donne son nom
à cette nouvelle place publique.
Henri Tranquille, propriétaire
de l'ancienne librairie
Tranquille et qui
n'est pas étranger
à la révolution du même nom.
L'ancien stationnement
pour les véhicules de police
a l'ambition de devenir un
incontournable du centre-ville
et pas seulement pour
la nouvelle patinoire,
où seront projetées des vidéos.
VALÉRIE PLANTE,
mairesse de Montréal
- Fait que ça se veut un lieu
vivant, on vient pas juste
au chalet mettre ses patins.
On vient au chalet pour manger,
luncher, se promener dans les
galeries, peut-être qu'on va
organiser une réunion avec
des collègues. Puis après ça,
bien, on chausse nos patins,
puis on vient patiner.
- Ce qui devrait être
possible dès mi-décembre.
Pour en arriver là, le projet de
près de 80 millions $ a traversé
trois administrations :
Tremblay, Coderre,
et maintenant Plante.
- Wow!
- Yeah!
- On est dans une atmosphère
de cour arrière des Montréalais.
Oui, il  va y avoir
des braseros, il va y avoir
des commerces, on souhaite
qu'il y ait du vin chaud,
on travaille avec
des futurs opérateurs pour
développer cette offre-là.
- Amener l'hiver au
centre-ville, mieux vivre
l'hiver avec la patinoire,
mais d'en faire un lieu
aussi vivant l'été.
- Je pense que c'est vraiment
important d'avoir des espaces
comme ça pour permettre
aux gens de se rencontrer
parce que concrètement, en fait,
on en manque, des espaces
de socialisation.
- C'est un bel ajout
à notre centre-ville.
- Au sous-sol, tout est prêt
pour qu'on puisse patiner
dès que la température
tombera sous les 10 degrés.
Avec un système qui permettra
des économies d'énergie.
CLAUDE DUMAS, expert en
réfrigération, Ville de Montréal
- Qui lui va transporter
la chaleur dans les équipements
de rejet de chaleur.
- Et chauffer en grande
partie le chalet.
Reste à trouver quel
restaurateur ouvrira
ses portes ici pour
contribuer à l'animation
de cet espace Tranquille.
Ici Mathieu Prost,
Radio-Canada, M